if you write down at night and you are
not utterly exhausted then you my friend
do not want it bad enough you have every
single thing you need to do whatever you
need to do and the only person stopping
you is you even if you people are doing
the exact same thing I'm not going to do
them in exactly the same way it's
unpossible you need to find people to
work with that work harder than you'll
get when you're in a room with them you
feel guilty because they're working to
harm you like holy crap I need ya la is
together
she's a Canadian youtube personality
vlogger comedian actress and rapper
since starting her YouTube channel in
2010 that her videos have gained over
1.5 billion views in 2016 Forbes listed
her as number 8 on the highest-paid
YouTube stars in the world she's
superwoman Lilly Singh and here's my
take on her top ten rule to success rule
number one is my personal favorite and
make sure to stick around all the way to
the end of some special bonus clips also
as Lilly's talking if you said something
that really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below and put
quotes around it that other people can
be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
whatever who is a girl superwoman real
name Lily singing you may or may not
know me but either way right now that is
absolutely irrelevant because I am
exactly like you I have so many dreams
in life and so many things that I want
to do that both excites me and stresses
me out I've had my heart broken so many
times now I'm totally terrified of
growing up I have so many things to do
and like to do lists and I tell myself
I'm going to do them but then I spend
more time making my to-do list and doing
things and I'm totally content in life
until let's jump onto Facebook and see
another stat it's about someone getting
engaged oh now a medium aardvark
googling pictures of Beyonce and jay-z
and let's just say although I'm not
their daughter I'm still feeling blue I
get it humans well the thing yet we're
so different not seeing dreams and
passions one of my passions is to spread
positivity and that mental to do in
these few minutes to you my friends so
it's come to my attention that a lot of
people in the world want to become
something they want to achieve some
things don't have reached some sort of
goal everyone whether I want to be an
actor actress I want to open my own
business I want a six-pack I want a blue
guy everyone wants something anything
everything you for example to take a
second think about what you want in mind
what do you wanna become what you really
really desire think about it you glad
your brain okay okay they're thinking
about it good good good now keep in mind
that there's so many other people in the
world right now that claim they want
something really really bad okay so the
purpose of this video is for me to stand
here and call you always say you don't
want these things so badly because if
you want them so badly you'd be getting
them now before you cut me off and close
this video let me break it down for you
if you lie down at night and you are not
utterly exhausted then you my friend do
not want it bad enough because if you
have a dream or a goal and the concept
of sleep is nothing for you then you
sleep too much because when you try to
reach a bowl please just feel like a
guilty pleasure okay you should go to
sleep at night when your head it's a
pillow that's right side in the straight
up we paid the lord i'ma get some Z's
and here's the thing right I hear people
complaining all the time about being
broke not achieving the goals nothing
else
their way but then those buffet people
have go to sleep compared to tired stop
working because they're too lazy can't
drive to a meeting because it's too far
cat network with people because they
don't like them well Catherine is a
project because the game is on you can't
take on a challenge because it's too
much work so can you I say hi hello
welcome to the real world where as hard
as you think you're working there's many
people working ten times harder than you
so let me ask you a question why do you
feel like you deserve success why you
deserve to reach new heights and achieve
great things because this is a reality
of your situation you can be doing
anything singer musician and you wake up
any spend hours and hours and hours
practicing and working on music and then
I night when your time you go to sleep
and you're like you know what I worked
really hard I can tell you that
somewhere out there there's another
musician who's choosing to stay up that
one extra hour and that's putting in
more grind than you my friend oka what
I'm trying to tell you is all these
people about dreaming instead of one
become something and say the world is
against them sweetie the world isn't
against you okay your excuses are
against you so hi hello my name is Lily
I go by the name of superwoman if you
don't know me now you do and we're
friends with rubbish
whoever you are whether you know we're
not watching videos or not you need to
see me for the first time you have a
dream you want to achieve something stop
watching this video sign okay well
what's the video is no harm in watching
movies we watch the video but after this
video k achieve something how do you
know not to touch the stove when it's on
chances are when you were younger you
burnt yourself a few times and now you
know if you touch it it's gonna hurt but
how would you know that if you didn't
burn yourself in the first place
as humans we learn to leak mistakes how
do you know how to walk because when you
were toddler you fell on your butt a
couple hundred times now that calls that
doesn't change over time when the moment
you were born to the moment you die you
will always learn things because you ask
things up or because someone hurts you
look back I want to take a second and
look back at every lesson you've ever
learned I can guarantee you that lesson
founded on strong mistakes heartache
tears and a whole lot of other sad
things if you learned who to trust is
probably because someone has lied to you
and if you learn how to be positive it's
probably because you've been negative
and if you have the app Find My iPhone
on your iPhone it's probably because you
lost your iPhone when you make a mistake
or you fail or your heart broken yeah
cry be sad about that's okay but also be
ten percent happy because you'll this is
going to teach you something amazing
that will help you in the future there
was a huge silver lining to everything
integrated exercise for your soul the
biggest mistake people make in life is
thinking that their brain controls them
when really they control their brain let
me show you right now touch your nose
no stop with your anywhere I'll touch
your nose you suck it you touch your
right
congratulations but oMG how did you do
that you did that because you told your
brain you wanted to touch your nose so
question for you why is it that when
you're scared of it or angry suddenly
you can't do things because my question
is how can you not do thing when you're
in total control of yourself you can't
be real do you can do whatever you want
to do as soon as you stop making excuses
and start taking ownership touch your
nose complete attack stand okay but hold
up okay let's be real this is you to
that we all know at least one person for
the comment below be like okay what if
my hands are tied behind my back
and there's a hurricane inside of a
World War and my dog ate my homework I'm
not in control then and this is what I'm
going to reference my good friend mr.
Bob Marley who said none but ourselves
since we are mine because although there
are CEOs there are parents and there are
presidents no one in this world has more
power over you in your mind things you
now don't get me wrong on you okay you
may have difficult circumstances indeed
but that's perfect okay
that's why you have such an amazing mind
and soul but you guys remember even
though your mind and soul are amazing
I mean they don't get hurt when they get
hurt you want to remember that negatives
aren't forever because let's be real
baby how many times have you taken a
negative and developed it into a
beautiful picture and if you can't
remember that in your mind you remember
you were younger and you lost your best
friend or when your dog dies when your
fish dies or last week when your
favorite game of film character died and
you were like this life is terrible I'm
never getting over this hi hello you're
still here and you're still existing I
see yeah that's because everything you
ever thought you couldn't overcome
you've overcome so logically it's a bit
ridiculous for you to assume that you
can't do things when you in fact been
doing them you have every single thing
you need to do whatever you need to do
and the only person stopping you is you
in life people will hate on what you do
and this is my take on it it's not
natural to the goal I'm going to go on
this girl video and run she's a hoarder
that's not a natural thing to do the
only reason someone would do that is
because they're dealing with their own
insecurities someone doesn't like
something they can easily ignore it but
when people feel the need to go out of
their way and comment on Twitter YouTube
and Facebook it just means that they're
just really freaking insecure and if you
do have answer to never be everybody
will have had a knack about at the end
of the day all the people I want to
tweet their weight comments on Twitter
on facebook on YouTube I'll never
respond why because you're still
watching what I'm doing you're
commenting underneath my video giving me
of you who's really winning even under
this video someone will write a comment
many people will why because they're mad
at what I'm saying right now and they're
mad that I'm calling them out they feel
bad about themselves and they wish they
could wear a winter hat in the middle of
summer and they wish they had you know
this friggin where is it people right
here they wish they did they what you
wish you did is not a hater that super
annoying it was like and you have a
hater that's super annoying and like
just keeps of all of you just agree with
them and tell them to shop F up so how
did you know anymore how did you know
how could I not have noticed that I'm
black I feel so stupid I can't believe
you knew I was black and I did oh my god
you're right I do eat curry and I am
smelly I'm gonna go take a shower in
Tabriz everyone says they're working but
I believe 1% of people are actually
working the other 99% of people are just
making to do is
and Lunas are great unless you're doing
them wrong which case they're totally
pointless because some people out here
treaty to do lists like their vision
boards like FN bucket lists like epic
life goals
tell me Kiku Lane have you ever made a
to-do list that looks like this finish
essay read chapters 1 through 5 buy new
jacket respond to all emails and inbox
clearance find true love grow hairs like
you let your brain learn to play chess
gets it back and about what you're to do
this looks like you my friend me to
combat okay because posters are
ingenious they don't make wishes come
true
Aladdin took place in a litter box not I
can often people and I know I know when
you're making it too delicious it's so
tempting to think you're invincible and
you're going to do all this stuff they
okay you were running it to do this it
looks like the effing lyrics to Rihanna
and Drake new song sex work where I work
or just cereal
I plan to choose to have to do lists
wonderful things you're going to do
today a game for you sleep and one for
longer term goals example today we
chapter one longer trimble three
chapters one through five if you want
even you have a third list called lol
where you write things like find true
love you know technical right I'm going
to blow your mind no one on this planet
is crazy in the same way that you are
crazy
no one is you don't have the same
characteristics as you which means no
one can do exactly what you do you know
two people are doing the exact same
thing I'm not going to do them in
exactly the same way it's unpossible -
dancers can't dance exactly the same -
artists can't paint exactly the same -
doctors will not feel people in exactly
the same way that's just a very fact
okay I know you think you know what's
absolutely why I mean so tumblr let me
explain those if no one can be exactly
like you that means it doesn't make any
sense to you to compete with other
people the only person yet to compete
with is the older version of yourself
with me you are going to succeed
are you ready that you are going to
succeed because the world is waiting for
what you have to offer because no one
else can offer exactly what you have to
offer and if you don't work hard and you
waste that opportunities that he didn't
show up to a job interview that you
already had in the bank
so now Megami or dun dun we got my
camera I know I see people stressing all
the time about this about that and what
problems in life and I'm here to just
keep it real estate your problems are so
important but really they're not
important at all and let me explain
something might be bothering you right
now
totally cool it is important your life
no one else understands that I'm a baby
look around life is waiting for you to
live it
so go ahead smile be happy making you
friend
take your trip treat yourself get up
randomly dance right now so be happy
because I promised you and important as
your problems are they are not nearly as
important as all the good things you got
going on I'm sure that's one of the
first time you present is significantly
easier to get work done when you're
surrounded by like-minded people in fact
that is almost half of the reason I
moved to LA but if entire volume of you
doesn't mean you're right moon Twitter
like contrary you can if you want but
you're not mean if you really yeah if
you're lucky the people who hustle and
motivate you are your friends looking at
be honest they're likely not I bet your
friends are so great at holding your
hair about while YouTube at eating
people with you and bursting with you
taking all these selfies with you
hanging out with you watching movies
with you great do all that stuff with
them it's a lot great at working with
you why are you with them when you're
trying to get work done you even find
people to work with that work harder
than you okay when you're in the room
with them you feel guilty because
they're working the harm you're like
holy crap I need to be online ish
together and that's not your friends and
so be it I mean that's okay to say hey
no you can't come over today I have work
to do different people work in different
situations feel confident dress to
impress yourself when you leave the
house look at the mirror look at
yourself and if you don't go Diane
then you need to Kate feel like a
million bucks and that doesn't mean you
to spend a million bucks you don't need
that Gucci Gucci Fendi Fendi Prada Prada
you can be rocking that straight 17
class on Walmart and still be hella hot
I'm saying make sure when you leave the
house you dress in the outfit that
controls confident in if you're worried
about your crack showing and you know
your booty popping out and your your
pants being some tighter tunes or
something you're not going to feel
confident these feels sexy you need to
go hot either you
okay and everyone is beautiful in their
own way so he me no BS book I'm ugly and
my peers ugly and my skin is ugly my and
my skin is all doing everything don't I
want a beautiful in their own way don't
give me that map okay I mean you just
need to connect with your inner sway and
get possible alright so you're sitting
there standing there lying there
watching this video and life has beaten
the crap out of you I'm talking straight
black I said but you're crippled
emotionally and mentally scars people
have hurt you it should happen you lost
your boyfriend you lost your girlfriend
you lost your job license 51 the general
over and over and over and over you jerk
cannot take it you give up I get it I do
I know what that feels like and so I'm
here to tell you to get the hell back up
if you fall 899 times you get back up
900 times
toss me I fall all the time I was
falling the most of my life that's all
on Monday on Tuesday the sun's still
roll and if I fell on Wednesday on
Thursday the Sun still goes because you
know life because it matters invisible
and all the world living
hair if you're in a good mood you're
happy the Sun will always still rise the
next day and you my friend will be left
behind full brother/sister solahart get
back up and do it for you let me tell
you what I mean by that exactly we'll
went out in time to seek revenge on
everyone who hurt them the world will be
a hot mess
more so than Oran is oh it killed Fido
by now I would have been a compulsive
liar and definitely would have bombed
rings headquarters I'd be a prayer I'd
be a crappy friend and I would backstab
people just for fun three slides of 13
guys just stopped yeah yeah but no
because two wrongs do not make a light
and a lot of people absolutely is the
reason you work so hard and try to see
because you want to prove all those
people wrong all those people that hurt
you and said you couldn't do it do you
want to make them feel stupid
come on answer honestly genuinely is no
my successor not be driven by the need
to make other people feel stupid
what would I accomplish by that but you
- that is your life you need to pull my
cell phone because back in the day there
people did hurt me they hurt me so bad
touch me I know what that feels like
but well remember no I want to kill
myself wrong because the moment I did
you're worthless
I did feel like I was a good enough so I
want to do that me wrong that all lilly
lilly annew I'll prove you wrong I need
to define my goal
other people longaniza to you the both
keep in mind all people approaching is
seek revenge on that no just remember
how they made you feel improve that love
because you're better than that and it
along the way a few people feel done so
yeah so this is this my video to tell
you I know if that happens my people
fall is ups and downs you may feel
worthless percent right now you may have
given up but I'm here to tell you to get
back up and do it for yourself
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Melvin Johnson
asked me to so this is the famous
entrepreneur that you are made of
profiles Nick leave it down the town
split oh and I'll see what I can do else
love to know what it Lilly says it has
the biggest impact on you what message
really meant the most to you that you're
going to immediately apply to your
business their life leave in the
comments and I'm going to join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Maria Rodriguez rishi
cup T V thank you so much for picking up
a cup of my book and share it on
Facebook I really really really really
appreciate it so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope to
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
pieces
you're pissed off or having a bad day
you just feel like the universe is
against you and everything going on when
you break it down you get few numbers
it's not even asked about you my friends
nobody cares to get you off ah hello
thank you a mother nature do Gandalf
friggin Dumbledore their mother is to do
cuz I'm not spending your time plotting
against you maybe I found that it's
simple if you want to have a good day a
splendid version I just think you could
just be rude in your way and be
obnoxious I know and they're gonna treat
you well you should write a book
hopefully dummies for dummies how many
let me break it down for you and you
spend out Batman by lying cheating
stealing anything making fun of people
gossiping posting a hate comment into my
YouTube videos you might friend up rate
your focus energy and attention on
negative ethos smoke your day what do
you think they're gonna recognize you're
there knowing that fat girl that idiot
guy that scratch on your caught up
person that cut you off we do this
totally ignore that fine guys the person
that held the door open for your call a
friend if you haven't seen a ten years
walk right button but not to dude you
might be starting them do you mind yeah
really how connector no good guys you
nee nee that need to know what I should
desta message you're a believer because
you so used to being a strong face it's
very simple stuff why not pick up your
phone
spend the night text message to someone
quick somewhere complimenting a tie a
supermodel and display messaging old
friend go hug your family you might
start to be aware of that software pause
the video positive I'll wait right
you're going are you back are you back
okay well now that you listen to me
anyway quit some about liked the video
thank you moving on I think one of the
best is I'm very big on in my show is I
don't like to say things that are cliche
or cute and adorable I like to be real
you know I tell my audience that some
people wish for their dreams and other
people work for their dreams to be the
person who works for your dreams not to
be pretty exactly cute assemblies fun
all the time
it isn't going to take a lot of hard
work and I encourage you all to do that
you know it's not enough to dream a
dream you got to work for it
Oh everyday everyday from the very
beginning on my South Asian female
making videos I mean I get racism and
sexism whenever one thing to mine of
course I think no matter what you put
online is in the controversy I've
learned very quickly on the internet you
cannot please everyone I have a video
called
ten reasons to smile and they're still
dislikes on it so I'm if that's an
indication that no matter what you do
people will just like it ended in
controversy over Ito me being an Indian
team we'll talk about relationships I'm
talking about kissing and talking with
those things and I just the best I can
do is do what I think is right and
that's it okay